[Music]
on the right
and do it right cause we coming at you
lots
[Music]
back at it again
foreign
[Music]
still you know why because I'm not beta
and I have a spine my spine goes
straight up towards the [ __ ] Moon
done shrimp no shrimp shrimp recording
shrimp require a feature act in 98.
you're looking you're looking strong
thanks man but I still have to adjust
the T-shirt like when you see you know
how you like you said yeah if the
t-shirt's in the wrong spot that's the
problem then it's a problem because you
never lose your body dysmorphia and
that's the most important thing I'll
never lose my buddies morphea he'll
never lose his body this morning never
look at that yeah what's that let me
adjust will you pick me up it's not
there's no weights anymore but it's all
about just staying flexible the swimming
feeling good the heated Pilates no I
don't throw any weights around Dane
pulled up to us in his Jeep sauce
so like hit the accelerator yeah peeled
out got out of the truck rubber let's go
and then you grabbed me and lifted me
off the ground yeah when I try to put
you into like a standing yeah it was one
where I pretty much control the the
guzzle yeah right
oh I couldn't get it up and I'd just be
like such a beta I'd be like I guess
here we go yeah have you ever done that
that's that's uh you feel pretty good
about yourself when you're in that
standing 60s that's when you're super
horny it seems exhausting it is
exhausting so that's why it's like you
gotta lock one leg out and then like
lean against a mantle or something right
there and then you're you're pretty much
just controlling the entire tempo of the
ride you put on knee braces she's all of
those that's when you get that's when
you get a [ __ ] good back workout
let's get a proper intro in here for me
guys
still doing it at the highest level
still doing it still doing it somebody
saw you the other day yeah and said the
[ __ ] is a flamethrower Gaga what
do you think he is what do you think he
stopped being funny
he got like older I was like you know
what I'm just gonna dial it in they were
like dude he was so fun oh really
somebody thought that I was going to be
coming in doing like uh you know what I
mean it's about 88 or something I got
mad at them I go I go I go wait a minute
Dane Cook was funny for 20 minutes oh
really
what he's never done that that must be
such a message I don't know Buccaneers
gave me like man Tom Brady can throw
yeah
maybe you're getting me that point
though in a comedy career you could go
out you could just dial in a couple of
lines and you'd be like I'm gonna hand
it over to scooty over here and I'm just
gonna and then you just sit and like sip
something and somebody comes out and
finishes and then you do an interlude
and back into the next beginning piece
of material that'd be good 31 years
slinging haha and I gotta tell you I've
never and uh true talk here permission
to speak freely please permission I feel
like I am dialed in and exuding and
being introspective in a way I always
hoped yep to get to that I kind of
thought I wasn't sure if it would happen
being able to really you know dig deep
go Inward and share some of the [ __ ]
scary things you know the trauma yeah
the cat the capsizing moments you've had
some you can't get there until you've
capsized you can't get there until
you've gone through the trauma that is
true right and do you feel like when I
when you and I were talking at the
Improv do you feel like the younger
generation and I I figured you knew it
was going to come but the appreciation
like the respect you have is like now
you're an OG like because you're like a
Pioneer right the Myspace and your
marketing I'm influenced by it Schultz
is influenced by it everybody is Kevin
and you were the first one to do it and
do you feel the because anybody I talk
to especially if they have a marking
mind every uh everyone mentions Danka
Danka and do you feel that respect I
think what I feel which I like more than
than the building blocks of whatever the
tech was at the time going oh you broke
in through my space or I think it was
the fact that comedians speaking of
comedians specifically are
entrepreneurial but we didn't really
know how to use the other 23 hours of
the day in a multi-hyphenated
aggressively wanting to be elected
comedy president kind of way and to see
so many Comics now like be able to like
you know tip the hat and go oh dude you
were one of the first people to really
figure out oh yeah yeah no this is this
is a full-time job it's not just getting
the laughs at night and hoping that
resonates or word of mouth it's what can
I do all day long to try to bring people
in the game has changed yeah yeah
it's a great and good way yeah but
anybody yeah anybody I know you guys
Talk Amongst I'm going to take it yeah
anybody anybody I know around the water
coolers gives gives Dane good credit
yeah like even we were last time we did
that set with uh Bill Burr at the Laugh
Factory we popped in on they were
talking to them and you got brought up
and he was like dude when that
[ __ ] I forgot you came up with
all those I always forget that you're a
[ __ ] Boston guy
Patrice uh Gary Goldman uh Bobby Kelly
one back from Rogan so we were following
Rogan kind of around town and watching
him like leather jacket [ __ ] like
just care like Crush all attitude no
touch but he had to and we had to
because the pillars in Boston at the
time were a bunch of monster that didn't
make it the Hollywood route and they
came back and not only were they just
masters of their craft but they were
sorry they were like they were like
we're not letting any of these dudes up
you know we're running to town yes we're
we're taking the cash the bag is ours it
was me it could be yes but it could be
but said this and he goes he was talking
about when you guys would come up he had
some bit where he was like you're a
T-rex or you'd walk on the tables he's
like follow nobody wants dude dude
how the [ __ ] you do he's walking on the
table I said then you gotta reset the
room he's like I said rush I said this
many times I there are two people I've
never seen Crush harder Dane Cook when
you would do those Dublin shows dublins
and Rogan he would do that two tigers
[ __ ] I have never seen I and I've
done some stuff I've never seen anybody
do that [ __ ] maybe Charlie Chaplin dude
when he would do he would you know he
got me back into comedy so when I saw
you have told me this a couple of times
so I would I'd stop doing stand-up I was
just an actor and I remember Rogan going
a very good actor by the way I just saw
Warrior again the other day it was on
and all your banter with the it was very
good thank you sir very well thank you
but when I when I I was I stopped doing
it I was an actor I remember I had a
conversation with Rogan he goes you're
gonna start doing stand-up again at 33.
he said that I go I'm thinking about it
you know and then I saw you at [ __ ]
dublins and I was watching you do like I
have a friend who has these terrorists
pets that buy some he had a pet Rim some
pet stock and my ram my buddy has a ramp
dude you're ranking it keeps ramming me
dude you have no idea I was we were the
the literally the place would you know
the Apollo where people would explode
that's what it was like and I remember
going home and I go I I have to do
stand-up I have to I gotta I gotta feel
a little bit of what that's like because
otherwise my life here's what's cool
that everybody I know has a Dane Cook
store like that like I got a few as well
yeah yeah like for for you and you don't
know this dude you know the first comedy
show I ever saw in La I came out with
Joe kleinstein our two girlfriends at
the time were saying some Terrible Hotel
in Hollywood you know we didn't have any
money these guys allowed to laugh during
yeah we're gonna welcome more we had
some Terrible Hotel we didn't have much
money and we buy tickets to the Laugh
Factory and Dane Cook he was the first
like Live come cover song yeah we're
like holy [ __ ] and then when uh Heyday
too that was probably like right when it
was really starting to get that would
that'd been uh
2006. that would that was when I
purposely would drive toward the club up
Laurel so that I could come over the
Ridge and see the line out there and I'm
not even kidding every time I saw it I'd
be like wow this is [ __ ] working man
this is so it was it was nothing it was
nuts like that yeah and I remember uh
the first time I ever headlined that
Laugh Factory I text I took a picture of
my and I was like remember the last time
you were here dude I was like look at
this man wow I've never seen Dane Cook
he's like holy [ __ ] dude you want to
sign that picture for you yeah please
that's and that's the only reason I
brought you here it's just a giant
laminated yeah here's the ticket from
there sorry guys they do this on air
here's the ticket by the way is this is
this lumbar because there's a [ __ ]
like a skull inside what is it right
what the [ __ ] is inside oh you know what
it is
it's liver because the liver King packed
it with liver that was the liver Kings
out there there's something that pokes
though yeah you're right oh right there
yeah no the liver King he's so rich he
brought his own table are you guys back
to one can we just do it right right
from the restart from the start let's
start off again let's start on the
picture I'm gonna sign it do we have it
guys props props get a pen it's got to
be the gold pen that but that time also
was like callan's in there were
full-time the lineups Harlan's in there
uh some of the guys that were coming to
Freddy Soto's in there like amazing
those shows are unlike anything thing
I'd seen before or maybe even to this
day I mean once in a while you'll get
one of those scorching lineups but just
showcase lineups those gigs man oh they
were something special and if you didn't
come in really ready to go it was going
to eat you up following I'd be following
someone he he would usually close it but
sometimes you have to follow him you'd
have to follow [ __ ] Harlan Williams
who's a monster oh my God I had to fall
in the other night monster I have to
tell you what Harlan did one time we
were doing a sort of a festival and it
was me and a bunch of comics I think
Steve Byrne myself just I don't know who
it was but everybody was you know had
had Headliners and Harlan got up the
last and did all of our sets in his own
words and did it did a collage of our
sets and destroyed and it took the
audience about three minutes to
understand what he was doing yeah we
were all like this
he's one of the best like
improvisational off the top you know I
put him in employee of the month and
that's every scene that Harlan did I
don't think he ever quite literally I
don't think he ever read anything that
was on the script ever ever we would go
into scenes and by the way we had Andy
Dickinson's which was like Bonkers but
but he's genius so imagine Andy Dick and
Harland and if you watch any of those
scenes because the movie is now a
classic
watch my shoulders because I'm like this
so many times because I'm just trying to
not laugh at these [ __ ] look at
both of them they're already hilarious
here's my favorite Andy Dick story Andy
came to set and he was very well behaved
and he was super lucid and cool
and we were a little nervous a little
trepidacious because you're not sure
what you're going to get with Mr Andy
Dick I don't know well the wheels came
off at week five
we had one more week of filming and Andy
just decided to go [ __ ] in NFL Blitz on
the entire
um big box store we were filming in and
he ran around and let's just say and I'm
going to be kind of like I'll try to be
political let's say he grabbed people on
parts of their body that maybe you just
don't grab you know it'd be frowned upon
right you guys today's culture he just
ran Rickshaw uh you know with his digits
hilarious it's usually some big dude
some big suit it was every kind of
person in that store because the store
was still open in some places where we
were filming the employee of the month
scenes and others an actual Costco yeah
yeah yeah so they they uh they the
police were involved and for the rest of
the shoot for the for the for the next
for the next week what what was that at
least we're involved was that Oh I
thought you were shushing me yeah me too
I'm trying not to laugh oh shoot oh that
was one of the most interesting laughs
I've ever heard Mexican people laugh
yeah
um so the police had to be there and and
the last I can I know the scenes the
last like week of filming it would be
like say I'm standing next to Andy Dick
and then out of frame you don't see one
foot away is a cop who had to stay
within six feet of Andy and so there's
scenes where I'm looking at Andy but I'm
actually looking at the cop who is like
standing right next to him making sure
he doesn't bolt and uh laugh the
periodically yeah he was he was having a
good time with it but Andy would pretend
to run away every once in a while and so
like four or five times they say cut and
then Andy would go like that in the cop
be like and then of course like on the
very last day of filming they go cut and
Andy really darts because the cops on
his wrong [ __ ] put you know is the
wrong ankle he's not ready to like
actually and then he ran around the
whole store again well now and he does
that on the streets of like Baltimore
yeah it's still hilarious oh he's so
hilarious
when when you got in the stand up
because there's been guys like Eddie
Murphy and you know Martin Lawrence
where you get so big Kevin Hart
obviously he's using your game plan but
it was Hollywood movies was the goal or
no
it was a hope but it was almost like
that just came through people that were
fans of the stand-up that were kind of
becoming what they were and producers
and and the executive side and you know
directors like Kevin Costner put me in
Mr Brooks because he used to come down
the factory he'll come down you check
out the shows and when I submitted it I
remember you telling me about this dude
yeah it's like I submitted a tape to
Costner and he wouldn't have probably
honestly watched it if he wasn't a a fan
of the stand up already so when he
called me he was like uh you really you
put some time into this tape and I was
like you know I want it I want to you
know go toe-to-toe and he was like I'll
see you in Shreveport and that wouldn't
have happened if he wasn't a fan of the
stand-up yeah Hey Kevin Costner what's
up with putting Dane Cook in Yellowstone
season five bro I'm already talking
about this next thing that he's doing I
said you know he hit me up about a month
ago he goes you know what today is I go
what and he goes 15 years since Mr
Brooks happy anniversary and we had a
really beautiful chat and that guy I've
learned more from Kevin Costner just as
far as like how to be a guy how to be on
set how to work your [ __ ] [ __ ] crew
and make everybody feel like it's just
you know it's it's everybody's prize
when you win and that is a Class Act of
the earth guy I just watched uh Bull
Durham and it holds up his flavor full
Durham so good so good so good I just
watched it so [ __ ] good what is it
shave that right we'll shave that God
damn it all right Demi Moore right he
looks like he was auditioning for zond
yeah but dude how hot was Demi Moore
in method actor and came into that uh
role by kind of treating me as the
character like you know I was a piece of
[ __ ] I was like this derelict you know
and and she was awesome man like I'm
going I'm in with a-listers in this
thing going in my trailer every day
studying up getting ready and being like
I got a shot here at like doing
something great with greatness and so I
didn't I didn't uh skimp on that I put
all the effort into that and I don't
know if today's game again it's better
for Comics because you have more You Can
Be Your Own Boss right you don't need
agents Hollywood to give you the okay
and you can put out your own special
whatever you want yeah you don't have to
have the executives like yeah this is
funny right right that's good but I
think those days are kind of over I
think as far as the comics
they're over in that nobody can trend
for long so so it used to be content
yeah you would do something and you it
would Trend so if you had a special you
do a special for the next year people
are repeating your jokes now there's so
much content that if they get through
five minutes of your [ __ ] you're lucky
because then they're going to the next
thing and I think our brains have been
so rewired with reels and tick-tocks
it's not because what happens is you you
what you your body of work becomes a com
uh something you consume like candy it
becomes like a niblet your body at work
becomes what it was that week that's it
so they get a shot of dopamine it
becomes it gets turned into what
Grumpier Old Man but it's true it
becomes a shot of dopamine instead of a
joke that people think about that that
sits with them no I was with a guy in uh
in San Jose doing this comic and uh he
was a guy sold out my first weekend man
added shows I'm like how long you been
doing these all three years I'm like
Jesus Christ and I go what sort of did a
clip man minute 30 clip like the mittens
just went viral I'm like oh [ __ ] that's
a career I'd be fascinated to like watch
because yeah that's tricky you know when
you get like invited into the Inner
Circle usually what normally would
happen is you you get there you know
based on maybe like One Shining Moment
you've had but then they're in the what
else do you got business yeah and so to
break through that rapidly and to be
able to fill the room I want to know
like but but I think I think that
because we're in an excerpt world that
and I this is even like front and center
of my new special it's even more
important there can be no garbage talk
there really can't be any [ __ ]
Flotsam and Jetsam you gotta put real
truth into whatever it is that you're
putting out there because I think that's
what Hooks people into wanting to watch
the next clip of you if they're getting
something you know something really real
as well as something really funny what
is this on above it all so right now
it's on I partner with moment that's
where uh that's where um uh Schultz went
yeah man he [ __ ] like what I I gave
him all his flowers on that because he
turned what was probably a negative into
a huge positive and this company who I'd
been meeting with before about wanting
to do this independently
um came to me and showed me like this is
our system this is our way of doing
things this is the way we run a contract
and it was so
um refreshing and different from the
ownership of Ip that comes with some of
the other yes Outlets that to me I feel
like this is the next thing it's not
YouTube it's moment is a is a website
yeah you direct to your fan yeah but
here's the great part you do a contract
with them that goes uh hey let's do it
like I did a 14 day run let's do 14 days
it's a page
they take a fee you get your IP back at
at the very end of the Run day 14 unless
they go you want to do another seven
days
after the 14 days but even better even
better at the end of the 14-day run they
give you uh you know a data sheet or a
little mini hard drive get everything on
it I have every email I have every phone
number I have all the region I have all
the analytics all everything they they
don't keep anything to go now come back
to us because we're the and what what
made you decide to go that route thing
obviously some guys before I've had
success with that like Lucy case kind of
the first one to talk to Louis about it
it's it is love you know looking at the
guys that have done independent release
of course like just looking at every
model that's worked and the things that
have definitely not worked for me over
the years and realizing they're going to
spend so much time effort and energy
chasing your royalties that to own and
operate your own material in a in a
world where like you're doing you're
creating your own network already why
pass it off to a person sin or people
that are going to then third party it
whether they say they are or not
those fingers are going to go out
they're going to receive a lot of income
and then the monetization that they
received you probably won't even know
about and then you're gonna sit and wait
for maybe a year or two for your
residual checks and why are they going
to hold it that's right because they're
making the interest of your money
holding it and you'll end up chasing
chasing I've had bad record deals that
I'm still in breach of contract uh
negotiations to to get back what I made
what I created that's what I was going
to say was there something that happened
where you're like I'm not going the
traditional route anymore I'm going to
do this it was probably a a mixture of
some bad deals along the way but also
realizing from my career early like when
I was selling these through my first
websites I was owning and operating the
whole day I was a fulfillment center I
was and it was more gratifying I like
what I'm doing right now I love this
more than any other opportunity to do
two or three or do you want a package or
do you want to no I'd rather just in
real time to be able to watch and see
where in the world my fans are enjoying
my stand-up so that I can better Target
what I want to do next Ben Stiller just
said about that great show Severance
yeah you're watching that it's good he's
not even getting the he's not even
getting the streaming data I think he
might have come out in like a Forbes or
Rolling Stone even he's like they won't
tell me how many well that's because
then you'll leverage what's it on well
you know Netflix doesn't give you any
analytics where's Severance on
and all they do is go hey man but they
know everything yeah we paid you in real
time imagine negotiating much it's just
it doesn't make sense it doesn't seem
legal but obviously it is but but here's
five million for your first special but
one of the second one to go here's 10
mil you're like wow double been there
that's all leverage for you if you know
you're getting this many streams that's
bombastic of course they're gonna be
like oh man now we gotta we gotta really
you know put together a great story
about capitalism though moment comes
along company like that comes along goes
here we'll solve that problem for you
yeah you know what I mean so I love it I
mean there is a thing to go into apple
or there is a thing about going to
Netflix they have market share they have
shelf space they're going to get it out
there if they know how to if you get
lucky enough for their algorithm but
you're right I think more and more you
know content creators are going to own
all their stuff which is such good news
for sure for the first time in the
business well I I think I you know what
I hope I actually hope it's a middle
ground Brian I hope that it's like
listen if you're a popular streamer
you've got a great splash page like skin
in the game this with me come at me
don't give me a five year or maybe you
own it in perpetuity like let's do
something where it's like all right this
is six months or a year and then what
that does is that puts the skin in the
game for both of us to bolster it
because we both want to win and it also
lets me keep up with the jargon of a
contract that when the uh the vernacular
changes from downloads to streams you're
still giving me a couple of pennies off
the dollar for for the old jargon but
now because the language has changed
they're allowed to be more willy-nilly
with how like dude I I know all the
legalese I've I've spent way too much
time with my attorneys going like
explain every page yeah I want to
understand this whole thing yeah but you
have your black business this is
with the successive moment once this is
done I'm gonna tell people a lot more
I'll be calling of the Nitty Gritty but
this is why we should be doing this and
why should we should all be doing it so
that other streamers are like let's do
something that's a little more
participatory yeah I love it yeah he did
you know and I've made bank it's like
and I self-finance the whole thing well
I paid out of pocket for everything
every drone Marty caller came in God
bless him you know just the guy that put
me on the map still making me look great
up there but to own and operate your
entire special and make it something at
my house
but you've always bet on yourself I
think that's why Comics respect because
you've always bet on yourself like what
was the special after you went through
the whole drawing with your brother
which we can get into or not if you want
to isolated incident yeah and didn't you
you took the money from that and then
you funded your own special right right
well everything after like 08 was me
owning my own catalog and putting it
back in there like so everything
Troublemaker isolated rougher on the
edges Madison Square Garden I own all of
those
and this because you know what happened
with his brother right yeah yeah he
stole that money yeah and then hey Dan's
been through some stuff okay you know we
were just talking I said when you get
older part of life when you get older
and you've been known each other for so
[ __ ] long you guys want to do a
prayer circle before you get into this
because I'm sorry I feel the whole
energy shift in here yes let me put the
tongue on the roof of my mouth eight
seconds in through yes I couldn't do it
but I got three solid seconds and then
exhale is good by the way my resting
heart rate is always 66 by the way it
never changes I'm mental you know what
that's it it's not even worth going into
because as you get older what you
realize is you're like we can indulge in
what's happened or we can just [ __ ]
have a laugh and move the [ __ ] forward I
don't mind I don't mind indulging
because I I am a uh I am a firm believer
that everything that's happened to me in
my life and I like to to impart this on
if I'm mentoring or just buddy buddy
with somebody it's it's not bad I don't
look at anything that's happen to me is
bad that's why I bring you up beat down
sometimes makes you want to [ __ ] get
up and be like all right now I know how
to actually fight back [ __ ] yeah but
that's why I bring you up because it's
so Dane because we talked about the
Improv it's that situation with his
brother and now this shows in life so
this is out of pocket you can tell me to
edit out but now he's thinking about
doing a documentary on that and having
his brother and shooting it together oh
that's a great idea dude dude that was
your brother is he out of jail he's out
of prison he served five of eight years
he's my manager
that's a little awkward now this is
awkward
check your account I was just gonna say
that well they're red flags I should
look for yeah
but he's reformed are you is he going to
be in the documentary
it's so dang good you imagine you have
lemon to Lemonade
I will I will tell you this it is if we
do our job if I won't do it so it's me
with a wig you're playing yourself if we
do if we do our job correctly the the
whole goal of this Doc is I want I want
whoever is going to distribute it to go
[ __ ] is this comedy or True Crime yeah I
want it to be an either or both columns
because nobody knows how dark I've never
I've talked about it you guys don't know
how dark it really got people don't
realize you told me the story I don't
know if you got not all of them not all
of them not the stuff that took years in
therapy to [ __ ] undo that knot man
you know those moments of betrayal where
you just stare at that [ __ ] knot and
go like all right what am I learning
from this where's the Dad did you find
when you go through like I I know
exactly what you mean by betrayal and
stuff did you find
that sometimes when you when you go
through something you lose your faith in
people or you get the Betrayal or
whatever do you hate people like me and
Brian yeah what happens is it's really
hard not to be [ __ ] way I was so
naive I liked everybody for real yeah
it's true
against a lot of people like me and Brad
yeah he's laughing because I like that I
like everybody like come on in my house
it doesn't matter
but but you get older and boundaries
it's hard to it's hard not to let it
affect your overall it's a truthful look
at the world it was not hard no I I even
though it crushed me because I loved my
brother yeah and I couldn't believe
that that um guys can we get some WD-40
for the chairs maybe at a break point or
something or maybe we could just do a
pause and adjust like a fox okay he's
gonna ears like a fox it's it's whoopee
cushions or something happening over
there it's really pulling me out maybe
one of those [ __ ] this is one of the
intense retention rate's gonna be so
[ __ ] for this episode
start again dude no no no in all
sincerity it did not throw my trust out
of whack because even even though I was
like in the uh undertow for a while it I
understood that it was him
I didn't start going like the whole
world like I was already in Hollywood
enough to know like okay piranhas a lot
of [ __ ] you know shitty people and I
I got the business out of it but it
didn't affect my personal relationships
the people that were in my life that I
loved were still there after and new
people coming into my life almost had a
better awareness of like maybe where I
was more mindful people were coming into
my life where you and your brother close
grown up live together yeah very close
and older younger brother yeah he's six
years older yeah my child is my tour
manager I tell him like don't Dane Cook
me dude it's your tree
your brother-in-law yeah from my mom's
previous marriage okay so same mom same
mom same mom so what's your Half Blood
Brother yeah yeah
and it but all this stuff that we're
gonna give them a heart if you walked in
right now would I give him a hug wow
that's an interesting question we might
see we'll have to see what happens with
the dude when you told me this at the
end I was like oh my God I'm so in we
might you never know who my but I will
say there's some interesting people that
want to be in the dock and and talk
about because we're going to cover the
upper echelon of Comedy because we have
to explain what was happening I don't I
didn't want to do a documentary about my
I'm a young 50. I'm almost 22 when you
look at me you got a 20 year old body
keep going thank you so where are you
moving thank you
my back is broken from this [ __ ]
chair after I leave here but the way you
move bro you float thank you he's 140
pounds dude I just [ __ ] brought you
up and I almost Swan Dive you right
right onto the knob I would never want
to fight that it wouldn't last a minute
what because you could beat me up or
[ __ ] upside down gobbles we're almost
taking place
Happy Thanksgiving you [ __ ] man maybe
for everybody
sorry bro sorry
so yeah I would like to see the edited
for television version of this
conversation where they just put like
banana and fishbone every other word for
some reason
banana fishbone bananas and then and
then the actuator version is just
[ __ ] [ __ ] and balls yeah the only
fans version but I'm not in that just
you guys but um yeah with uh with the
doc it's just not gonna be focused on
this be the whole comedy because you
want you know what I like when you talk
about philosophy it's rare when you talk
about it because when you talk about
coming up in the Boston days yeah for
for like a younger comic I I love
hearing about those days yeah and the
guys and like just the the you guys were
such Savages man yeah like all the guys
it had to be because the the whole scene
was predicated on men doing comedy and
it was like the Lenny Clarks and the Don
Gavins and the Steve Sweeney's these
guys were just [ __ ] like they were
like they were intimidating sitting at
the back of the room before they were
set you know this wasn't the comedy
scene team where you thought everybody's
just like you want to write some jokes
together let's talk each other up it was
like you know you do four minutes if you
do four and a half I'm throwing my beer
at you get the [ __ ] off at four yeah all
right and don't do any of that and they
tell you something you shouldn't do and
you'll be like
dude I got five minutes you know you had
to earn their respect it was a hazing
back it was a real hazing and guys like
Burr like I give credit to burb because
Burr was so different in stand up like
he's probably the one who who evolved
the most agreed his early stand-up was
like his shtick was like kind of like a
little I'm the dork and I'm kind of
goofy and you know Bill Burr and like so
mad no no it was like it was really he
was a dental assistant it's different
yeah he was a dental assistant with you
know Ginger and a scrawny pasty kid who
when he came in it was like he had
Patrice who's just like Savage from the
beginning
and then even Bobby Kelly at some point
was just like Bobby real ball buster you
know what I mean like like when the show
went into disarray he was so good at
like
um like if there's like a loose rope it
[ __ ] wrapping it around his hand
[ __ ] being like pulling it taut and
like Bobby could like but he would do in
that that manly Boston you know Winthrop
Massachusetts kind of like you know I
live by the Sea I'm [ __ ] you know
what I mean I have to like lean in the
window like this yeah I saw him do that
in front of 1500 people in Vegas at uh
Beatrice madhouse yeah oh boy after
after [ __ ] Paris Hilton got up on
stage and I was like what she had she
was just saying something and they're
like and they didn't want any comedy
yeah and Bobby Kelly got up there in
front of 1500 people who did not want to
see it at all they were just like [ __ ]
they didn't know they needed yeah dude
it makes it look like it's nothing oh my
God he is a special finally the barbecue
I think CK directive he did actually
that's awesome Bobby Kelly and Bobby
Kelly he talks about Schultz Bobby Kelly
said people don't realize the Mastermind
that Louis CK is because Louis gave you
know his uh whatever Grammy
award-winning staff or Academy
award-winning staff yeah they're like
they're gonna produce it for you he's
like I just thought he'd hire like a
regular production company he hired his
staff so who win all these Awards right
and then I guess Louie came in he did
this with uh Rogan too Louis came in and
was looking at the setup because he was
like Bobby you need to do this in a club
comes in he's like we need to move this
movement and Bobby's like no it's good
to go he's like it's not he moved this
added 45 seats here changed Angels here
and Bobby's like dude killer deal with
Rogan's new club Rogan took him and Lou
was like uh you gotta do this wow that's
great Savage well we all came up you
know Louie those guys Rogan Maron they
were kind of ahead and they were leaving
Boston and we were just you know what it
is you had to be a Wrangler you had to
keep that crowd because oftentimes it
was uh aggressive combat zone downtown
wasn't the Theater District we know now
it was rough man roughness and
prostitutes hanging outside and just
working class that's the good stuff
Austin people don't realize how
aggressive Boston is yeah Boston is a
place where if you go to a bar it's so
easy to this day to get into a fight
it's so but back then right back [ __ ]
then I it was I'm telling you I say this
all the time and correct me if I'm wrong
you would go to a bar to not see a fight
at least one fight a night was it truly
I'm not joking that that sounds changed
a little bit it was it was a fight these
cameras and lawsuits because of money
back then you the bouncers were no
[ __ ] job I'll tell you what it was it
was a fight that then would uh you know
it'd be like Haymakers in the packed uh
you know bar and then what you would see
is that person would get uh yanked
they'd get roughed and then thrown and
then you'd look out the window and you
just see a dude with some blood spitting
for the next 15 minutes pacing waiting
for his friends to probably finish their
drinks or whatever he just got his
[ __ ] ass handed to him and you just
watch him out the window as he was like
Surly and spitting blood 10 degrees
yelling at the building yeah that was it
man there was no yeah no lawsuits No
cameras in your your class of comics is
who who did you come up yeah it was Burr
Patrice Goldman came like a year after
Bobby Kelly and then like there was a
bunch of like Bob Marley's and like just
Killers just Comics that like came again
the ability to leave your act Kim Brewer
Jim was I don't know if he hopped a lot
from New York but once I went to New
York it was like all right now I'm in
the pits with you know a towel and
Brewer and a young Chappelle and yeah it
was like oh Boston's gonna launch me in
New York and then that'll be relatively
easy uh you know because now I'm used to
these Rough and Tumble crowds and then
you get to New York and they were like
they'd already cut off the fat and they
were even better so you couldn't bring
any you know Greg Giraldo dude it was
just remember those guys oh my God just
just monsters man you we we all came up
like knowing that uh how big how big
would Patrice O'Neal be today if he had
a podcast I think how many tickets he
would sell dude because he was like one
of the original like outliers who just
didn't take he was also closed all the
doors on he also thought so differently
that's what I'm saying like hit with his
brain and he could do a he could be like
a Tim Dylan or Joey Diaz and just ran
into the camera yeah how many [ __ ]
tickets a guy would sell today with his
stand-up today's culture he was was he
was like in that uh Chappelle thing
where it's like he was just uh
transmitting on a different level we all
knew like at the very beginning like
watching Patrice was like damn how long
will it take me to to be able to like he
just he abandoned the ACT you'd see him
and then he'd just be in real time
talking something out like you know
what's really on my mind and then he'd
go into this thing that was even funnier
and uh so we we definitely came up with
a squad of you know dudes for the most
part that we were just constantly there
was a lot of ball busting but there was
still a lot of like champion each other
because we all wanted to get out of
there what about even when because all
you guys basically made it in one way or
another in a way like you did but even
after I mean that bird definitely like
yeah
already gone yeah Louis was already in
his room writing career next Rogan
skipped and then was like news radio and
stuff like it was in L.A yeah but then
once once you guys made it did you guys
stay tight or no
I mean for more comics for a lot of
years it was like still bringing each
other on the road here and there and
like when I when I made it and then I
finally had um Vicious Circle you know I
had Bobby and Gary on tourgasm because I
wanted to share in real time that
Spotlight and what was happening to me I
was basically saying to those guys like
you know come on in like you know I'm
rocking but pull your fans from here
because we're kind of similar yeah it
wasn't like you know same brand just
first of all had that like a certain
Affinity correct in a certain way that I
think my crowds appreciated those guys
and it was a great turning point you
know sharing that uh sharing that moment
with my buds was really really magic
gratifying was Kevin Hart around then or
he was after you guys Kevin came later
but I sat at dinner one night with Kevin
Hart and Jamie Foxx before uh he's still
just little Kev in New York City and he
told me he's like man I watch for
Myspace and I'm doing the same thing
with my audience and he kind of told me
like what he you know he really had kind
of studied what I what I was doing and
then what he was like I'm gonna change a
couple things tell me and I remember at
that dinner being like giving Kevin's
energy and enthusiasm and likability
coupled with now he's gonna start you
know parlaying it in with this you know
digital realm I had a good feeling that
he would have the success well he's even
exceeded it but I was like he's gonna
break yeah he's gonna have his moment we
almost couldn't understand why he hadn't
already but he figured it out I had
Jamie Foxx come up to me at this party
and talk about stand up okay and he's
the one guy who was like talking about
how he had done a set in DC for the
first time in a long time and like I'm a
huge fan of his so I was a little bit
geeked I was like you know uh three
years ago maybe maybe ah God three years
ago I was going to say a year ago
[ __ ] three years ago and [ __ ] time
but he he uh the piano snap kind of
Frozen I think he'd seen something I'd
done and he was saying nice things yeah
and
I was listening to him but I'm a big fan
like I love his acting I just like
everything about him yeah yeah and I
said yes dude I go man I'd love to see
what you could do with an hour I'd love
to see because back then I think he was
doing a lot of stand up wasn't he I mean
or no he was he was also doing like was
that around like um uh Any Given Sunday
it was almost like he was doing that
because he was doing TV like I could
tell I'll tell you a story about that
movie too because I could tell that he
so badly wanted to stand up like all I
got from him was like he was like he
likes doing movies but movies are boring
I don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says
and there was like this longing and he
was talking about how he did it he did
10 minutes in in DC and how it went
really two years and I was like yeah and
yeah when you take years off I don't
give a [ __ ] who you are you got to go
back in the ring yeah he's a special
he's a mom yeah the worst thing that can
happen is the Year's off and then your
name gets a bigger Ovation than what
you're ready to look up to that's the
problem you're in this like prison where
you can't you know that's why you must
have felt that though like after what's
special I've always been great I got to
tell you man I've never worried man I've
never let myself down we are the
champions where it's uh yes but you've
never taken time off however you
remember a long time ago you were at the
top of everything
and I go what are you gonna do uh this
summer or something and are you doing
touring and you go I'm thinking about
putting the microwave forever
and I was like what yeah and you go
where do I go from stadiums like what do
I do here I really yeah I remember that
it was yeah yeah that was like I think
that was before I gave myself permission
to go no I love it I love it at a small
Club I love it on my front porch I love
it on any stage and I and I realized
after that era like oh I don't have to
prove this again yeah you did it I did
it now I have now what I have to do is I
have to figure out where do I want to
take my audience now I'm growing up like
right now I've got this it's wild like
I've got my generation of Comedy fans
that I came up with their kids start
seeing like employee of the month down
in real life or maybe it's planes now my
fans College age are bringing their kids
they're seeing me they don't know I'm a
stand-up yes they know I'm Zach from and
they don't know I'm there to [ __ ]
like exceed my own expectations every
night so then these new fans are like
man I didn't know it was going to be
like that yeah that was just going to be
you yeah the guy from the movie with a
couple of quips yeah it's like no man
this is what I do this is my birthday
dance for me to get me so geek because
I'm like there are young people that
they're actually listening that makes me
feel really good yeah like I'm not dying
yeah I feel like I feel like you're
dying yeah yeah I feel like regardless
of age the one good thing about this the
the re these things happening in real
time through these apps it is
diminishing time and of a time because
if they see a piece of content you could
go through that like you'll see
something from like the 1950s you'll see
something a lot of 80s stuff like and
the fact it's all swirling around
together I think the Next Generation has
more of appreciation for just real funny
[ __ ] or real [ __ ] regardless of how old
you are where you're from and that's
that's great that's great for everybody
you don't feel like you're um you have
an expiration date on your career
anymore let's take a little break
the legend buddy yes the legend Dane
Cook yeah not a legend but your boy's
working I'm in Salt Lake City this
Thursday Friday we're not being a legend
Wise Guys yes guys one of my favorite
clubs make the keys shout out to Keith
one of my favorites uh Salt Lake City is
this uh freaking weekend Thursday Friday
Saturday we have a fight companion on
thick boy dot thick boy YouTube uh for
UFC 280 me and Frank Mayer okay you said
okay I was asking what did you mentioned
let's go north into Canada all right
Brian I'll do it for you I might get
stuck up there well all right you know
it's tough but you don't do something
like don't do like Winnipeg or somewhere
how about Calgary does that work Calgary
next Thursday cowgate the rooftop
downtown Kyrie because that bad boys
almost sold out we had a show on Friday
what at the rooftop that's next Thursday
Friday October 27th 28th Calgary Canada
baby I ask you a question yes you don't
neglect the US and don't never don't
neglect a state that's as American as
apple pie I'm talking about taxes all
right how about if I did San Antonio and
Houston only back to back weeks what
November 3rd San Antonio through the
fifth Houston November 10th through the
12th that's crazy talk text if you tell
me you're going to do Milwaukee
Wisconsin my dad's Hometown on November
18th so who else's Hometown clock out
Jeffrey Dahmer Jeffrey Dahmer's Hometown
he's popping around you better not do
that if you tell me you're gonna go to
The Comedy Zone in Charlotte I'm gonna
freak out before that you're going to be
in Chicago improv not Chicago though I
got to go to London and then I'm going
to go after I go to London Brennan I'm
going to go to the Chicago improv
October 27 28 29. then I got Charlotte
North Carolina Comedy Zone November 10
11 12. then Addison Texas that it's an
improv November 17th then Naples Florida
off though December one through four now
here's the thing I need to stay calm
when I'm traveling I don't like
inflammation I'm off the road yeah I
just wish there was some kind of a tinct
or some kind of an oil I could take that
I could absorb I need something that has
smart sorb uh technology that's all
because I want to absorb not two percent
ten percent but ninety percent of what I
actually I actually get you need some
CBD but just not any CBD you need next
Evo we're talking about great CBD next
I use the Sleep CBD right knock your boy
out on the road now your drone's going
yeah Parts racing I take two of those
pills three if I'm feeling yeah I needed
to absorb in like as little as little as
10 minutes that's what I'm saying well
we got you covered man yeah but do they
have gummies and capsules yeah whatever
you want dude and listen you're talking
about 90 of what you think is actually
getting wasted not with well 90 of what
you think you're getting is actually
wasted yes dude right we're talking
clinically proven smart sword CBD they
combine it with a patented uh curcum
it's curcumin curcumin cumin yes with
CBD and apparently you you absorb it
four times better okay so it's smart
sorb CBD you combine it with patented
curcumin it's a I think that's like a
spice of some kind sure don't settle for
less get your supply of next Evo
Naturals revive CBD complex today or
shop their gummies capsules mitts
whatever you want proven absorb four
times faster than standard CBD oil and
he can trust him get 25 off when you
subscribe and spend 40 more at next
evo.com recover with promo code fighter
that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash recover promo
code fighter B I know you're excited for
the UFC this week dude Peter yawn and
our boy sugar
tjv Sean Brady Muhammad I can't take it
that's right UFC 280 is here get closer
to the octagon with draftking Sportsbook
the official Sportsman partner of the
UFC right now new customers can bet just
five dollars on UFC 280 and get 200 in
free bets if your fighter wins if you
have tried draftking Sportsbook today's
the day want even more action cool you
can also double your winnings on a same
game parlay combine multiple bets like
which fighter will win how long the
fight will last and more all right
listen Charles Olivera machachev uh if
you want to make some Bank you don't
really want to bet on the favorites
unless you do a parlay which you can
combine the favorites in the parlay but
I like uh Charles a lover not to not
only win but do it in a parlay where he
gets it done before five rounds that's
the bet all right everyone who wants to
boost their winning play so UFC 280 same
game parlay today download DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use promo code finder
throw down five dollars on UFC 280 and
get 200 in free bets if your fighter
wins that's good fighter this Saturday
at DraftKings Sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the UFC
minimum age eligible restrictions apply
see show notes for details so after
after doing handling all yourself doing
the special yourself yeah you're always
going to do it this way or if Netflix
came back next year was like Hey dude we
saw the numbers yeah it's kind of one of
those things where you go if somebody
backs up a Brinks truck of course you're
going to be like hmm let me consider
that because the big kick from something
like that and and or I don't know if it
still is prevalent like this year as
maybe a few years ago it's like tickets
on tour people being able to get access
to your stuff instantly and going like I
want to come see you in terms of just
I want to own my stuff I want to own my
IP and I want to be able to like someday
give my catalog to my family yeah you
know what I mean so and I have been
fighting early stuff in my career to
this day of just ownership over things
that I made like literally designed and
made myself and I don't want to go
through that legal battle for the rest
of my life so if there's a middle ground
where somebody sees above it all and
says because I'm I shot two at once I
shot part one and part two over Friday
and Saturday night well at your house
I'm editing part two now so now with the
success of the first one if somebody
were to look at like you know my account
balance and what I've recouped and where
I'm going from it like good business
would be to say yeah we'll take it but
let's also not put like a eight year
window and you have to wait until year
three to get your money that's nuts you
did that in your front porch you have
part one and two yes I'm editing two now
was an hour an hour or what first one's
an hour second one will probably be like
an hour and 20. I had to cut out like
all this I had like great
I did a whole new set I did two
crossover bits that I wanted to cover
twice but I watched Friday after Friday
I was like I got it I don't need to
[ __ ] edit like I don't need another
angle like I got it so I then I ran two
hours on Saturday night that was all the
other stuff that I wanted to accomplish
and now we're cutting the seconds how
are you gonna how are you gonna release
all that then well it's two specials so
two and a half special so right now part
one will be like after moment then next
week it reverts to I'm meeting with
distribution people now so I might go
with like a 10 finger distribution that
means you put it in 10 places instead of
one why keep it on one spot when I'm
gonna be able to you know possibly
um uh uh exploit many different revenue
streams I've got a shitload of Clips too
that you can do Clips all that stuff you
know that all leads to monetization but
then it's like okay now I have part one
part two queued up to either follow suit
on that whether I I keep it on
danecook.com or you know meeting with
Roku 300 million televisions have Roku
or like there's great other resources
that also want you to be like a partner
in it and will give you back yourself I
want my content back yeah okay because
we've all seen what happens when you
don't get it back years later you start
going now I'm only getting a fraction
but that shit's everywhere who's
recouping on that because I'm not
somebody yeah well and I know who some
of those summities are but the reality
is I want to own my content I just want
to be able to like and and it's um it's
a
valuable way to do it if you're
zeitgeisting and can get yourself out
there like I can to go I'll recoup and
now everything else is you know like
money while you sleep money and I didn't
have to edit anything out this is the
[ __ ] show
people are seeing this show and
first of all when you make any comedy
show it's got to be very funny right
yeah just wanted to be very funny but I
wanted it to be
um introspective I want to talk about
some of the things in my life that were
like scary things that have happened to
me that are like that are um
you know have encumbered me it's in
certain points in my life give us an
example uh well I tell a whole story
about a stalker that I dealt with who
was trying to find me and was like I'm
going to kill you I'm going to [ __ ]
kill you years of videos
of of her finding my house years with
the LAPD working on this case coming out
of my house like on a pivot every day my
girlfriend about how can you say it
what's that oh [ __ ] yeah no I told she
[ __ ] she came to my house and shaved
her eyebrow tell the whole story in the
in the routine but she shaved her
eyebrows and sent me the video Standing
on my porch of her just doing all this
healthy she actually works with me now
she's online
they work in Full Circle
but it's also like horrifying with that
LAPD that cop was like let's say that
part it's like yeah no no I don't know
if you told this to me okay yeah yeah I
don't know how much you told me and how
much is something special I haven't seen
it it's like because some of the things
I guess
watch her feet being yeah yeah it's all
in there it's being able to like
nobody's gonna tell you to cut your [ __ ]
nobody's going to tell you you should or
shouldn't have this bid you release it
the way you want to release it and then
you get to for me show a whole different
I invited people into my home because
this is the most personal material but
it's also got the lpms the last per
minute if you know comedy jargon as we
all do then um it's like that Perfect
Blend of like if I brought this some to
somebody else they might have said can
you change this or maybe do this with
the opening or like I don't want to do
the stalker right right or something
that I might have said that was too
caustic the fans didn't know that
they're going to your house no so how do
you put the word out there's a company
you can hire out here called one iota
and they will put together
um crowds for whatever venue and so I
hired them and I said can you shuttle
people from this parking lot that I'll
rent don't tell them they're coming to
my home and don't tell them it's for a
special just say it's a secret Dane Cook
show so they got real Die Hard fans who
didn't know they were going to be on my
way is that my front lawn yeah 30
minutes later dude it was awesome it was
amazing are they allowed to go in the
house I didn't let anybody in there I
did and you know what I let one guy in
the house who came up to me and he said
uh he said can I get a picture with your
refrigerator I'm a big fan of your
fridge I've seen you post about it
because I have this
I'll give you the code to the front door
it's horrible with stalkers it was wild
though man it was unlike anything I've
done in honestly in my career there's
two things that I wanted to do
accomplish and I got to do two once
which is I wanted to film something on
my on the porch of that house for a lot
of reasons I wanted to bring people uh
closer to me than they had been before
with the comedy but with something else
that it was meaningful to me and I
wanted to Premiere it at the um TCL
Chinese Theater which was always there
for us which I was out of town although
I've been there yeah they do a premiere
for us so far which again you know the
man theater launched it himself but then
nobody's done the premiere that's the
other thing you son of a [ __ ] and I'm
sitting in the bunch of themself no
one's done the premiere I'm sitting
there and and then I was like you know
what let's add a third and then I
masturbate it to myself
Chinese Theater in the back to my back
yeah yeah instead of veins staying you
know how I laughed I laughed like this
damn it
way to ruin everything
God damn it that's incredible dude yeah
that's pretty sweet man that is awesome
now what's next what's next Dane are you
gonna do stand-up do you think you'll be
doing standard 80 . you ever think about
this [ __ ] I think so too yeah I love it
how long did Carlin do it I love it till
he died I love it literally I love it so
did Richard I'm Richard Pryor they had
to wheel them up yeah you never so did
uh so did uh [ __ ] uh George Burns
George Burns died at a hundred and I
think he just kept going I love stand up
I'll always do stand up I I feel like
I've accomplished everything I've wanted
to do now and stand up so it's gonna be
cool to go back to like square one and
kind of figure out like what do I wanna
share next like what do I what do I do
because I really I really just like put
it all into this it's four years later
right yeah no probably could be
something like that but then it's behind
the camera I've wrote A series that
um my side company duffel bag
entertainment moniba bot is my uh yeah
duffel bag
um uh great story behind that but not
for another day but I'll tell you a wild
story While I Work duffel bag but
um and we're developing uh a series that
I'm hope hoping to also I want to direct
more I directed a short film we made it
all the way to um
Oscar qualification we made it from the
submissions to the final 140. [ __ ] short
films where they hit us up and they were
like man you made it to the literal last
second to last and I directed and
co-wrote that so probably more of that
so you won't be behind the camera
instead of love it instead of say action
love it
action Jesus dude your voice right in
you're really dominant you kind of could
feel like I believe I was already
believing I wanted to act I was insert
then let's let's why don't we act right
now here's the scene okay you're a guy
sitting in a chair yeah you're dealing
with something in his throat yeah yeah
I'll show that I'll show you clear
enough cancer yeah I'm not ready I got
something for you ready this is going to
be a real challenging performance okay
this is what this is what's going to
happen uh this gentleman your character
is going to be um witchcraft number one
okay okay and you're just gonna look at
him you're sitting back in the chair
you've never had use of your hands
they've never moved you've never been
able to feel them move them nothing and
then whatever you're going to say you
can improvise a line put the put the you
know the magic Juju over there and then
your hands for the very first time
you're gonna have feeling in them and
then you can take it wherever you want
to go and
action if you buy this potion your hands
will work
I don't believe in magic that's so
stupid
what what
[Laughter]
are you smelling it's 150 000 a day to
keep doing this
it's as small as you think and cut okay
let's check Gates that was great we're
at lunch you want more I can give you
more no that was perfect I can give you
more whatever you want I like that you
went into smelling that that's a natural
thing that you'd probably do though do
that you would yeah and then I I've
never felt my hands on my face yeah I
certainly haven't felt I'm on my piece
exactly on my piece I call it my Pace
dude and then I was gonna go I was gonna
go
a sparrow and then you think I'm gonna
release it and I go
okay
with my hand because I use my hands now
you kill me though
Foo Fighters walk kicks in with the
acoustic version and your neck is thick
and I'm like your neck is crazy it's a
commercial for iron neck yeah for the uh
I'm like do you have a skinny neck yeah
so you know how I go that's that's I
can't wait to see this you're gonna
animate this whole part right is this
where it goes into an animated Town
somebody's gonna do that now yeah good
good that was a very good direction
sure current events director would give
me an adjustment that that's usually you
have to no no
no so long okay yeah that I no notes can
I be very honest with you yeah I already
knew coming in I wasn't even going to
use this scene but I figure we're all
set up we had lights and so it was fun
cameras I'm doing the Joker third day
I'm third day sitting around with the
rear bar and speaking of great comics
and a couple other guys and I I'm just
sitting there watching how the scene's
shot I've been doing it so long and I'm
like
what's up I go
I'm not in this movie am I sorry because
he goes I hate listen I don't know I'm
sorry probably not it was so great I did
a scene with uh Matt Damon and Greg
Kinnear in uh stuck on you and I was a
cop and I pulled them over and I heard
Matt Damon say as I was walking past him
to lunch uh something like uh well we're
gonna cut it anyways and I knew I wasn't
going to be in the movie and I wasn't in
the movie oh I'm gonna cut it anyway you
know Adrian Brody was in Thin Red Line
and and he really he was in every huge
part he brought his entire family what
his entire he's cut out of the whole
movie literally there's a great story
about he cut his whole family and
they're all there and and and he was
just like he was like oh no and he ended
up not in the movie
so so Frank Grillo when he was he was in
uh Minority Report and I remember we
were God we were so young and I go can
you imagine being in like a Tom Cruise
movie or something and he goes I am and
I go right he goes dude it's crazy and
he's gotten the role I was like what and
he goes it's different back then when
you got a movie like that it was
different oh yeah it's different the
word of mouth instantly forget about the
success no I'm not gonna move you're in
it you made it yeah you're in it Stephen
Spielberg and [ __ ] right and a big part
yeah big part you cut the trade uh piece
out you stick it on your magnet and
bring girls over if you're not if you
don't have a film career you're
definitely getting a TV show right so I
was just like bro this is [ __ ]
incredible I couldn't believe it it was
just like and plus it was there some
really good friend of mine that it makes
you closer to it you know I'm just like
oh wow so I go
now they don't back then they didn't
tell you anything I went to the movie
yeah to see my my boy does he say what
he's supposed to be doing like what are
you waiting for to see he played the cop
or something
I'm chasing him but he's a cop chasing
Tom Cruise okay awesome front and center
and there's a whole plot line and
everything else
[Music]
I didn't go to the premiere I went to
after and I swear to God this was my
dear friend you see him go like this you
see the back of his head and then you
see him go like this that's it and he
goes he goes I don't know
not even a line he goes and I said to
him I go what happened he goes saw like
the first 15 minutes and I went oh no
there's nothing you can do nothing you
can do and he had all he had his family
it was just like that that was it you
ever met Tom Cruise yes I have twice
okay I did a reading with him yeah and
then I what's the reading for I love Tom
Cruise stories so it was it was Todd
Phillips I'm I'm doing I'm about to
Virginia Tech I'm on this tour stand up
wise and he goes are you are you in L.A
like oh no he's ah [ __ ] I had the
sickest thing for you I go what he goes
I was gonna have you do read all of Owen
Wilson's Parts across some Tom Cruise in
this reading it was only you Eric Stoltz
Amy's Amy Smart and that's it and and
like at his offices oh my God so I was
like I go when is it and he goes it's
tomorrow forget it I go no not forget it
yeah I'm not doing stand-up I I was like
I'm not I was headlining I I can't do it
right right I go I'll be on a plane I
find a way to get on the [ __ ] plane I
I get I'm there the next day I go to Tom
Cruise's office I'm I'm I've been
reading it on the plane the whole time
oh all my scenes are with Tom Cruise and
we're right here is your heart racing
the whole time well no I just kept
looking at him I had to stop staring at
him because he was a piece of History
right of my history his magic the
unicorn and all the all the posters were
behind him so I kept looking at him and
I was like movie posters yeah in his
faces oh that's wild yes and he has a
small face but I'm looking at a small
place or face face okay so all the all
the [ __ ]
when we started supposed to have big
heads he didn't and I'm like and I'm
looking at all and I swear to God he had
he goes I'm so sorry guys I'm so sorry
and he had what did he have for lunch
he came in a little bit late really
apologized yeah he had six pieces of
Yellow Tail from masuhitsa across the
street with a tiny little jalapeno on
each and a glass a bottle of Penta Water
which is that that ph balanced water
that's what he had at least tell me this
whole thing was this Scientology no not
at all then then we so then it just
brings me a conversion now now we do the
reading and then he wants to hear from
every one of us about what we think of
the movie oh wow so now and dude when I
tell you that when I'm talking he's
listening to you like this yes
like he's and then he's and he's so
invested he goes hold on hold on hold on
are you saying he's into it and yeah and
he's going wow that's a good and it
didn't matter the idea I don't know if
my ideas were good I don't know if
anybody's ideas were good but he was so
invested yeah so then we're done dressed
like this at the house I may as well Ben
yeah no I'm at his office then after
that
I get this from him
you're very talented
you're very talented he looks at me like
this and I'm like thank you I had two
pit bulls in Venice I don't know how
they found I had a picnic table in my
backyard my pitbulls were there two
pitbulls there was a giant [ __ ] fruit
basket my girl calls me this you have a
you have a fruit basket wow a gift
basket from Tom Cruise the biggest thing
you've ever seen cheese fruit thank you
for your talent and time posters of him
yes
I still have the note yeah thank you for
talent time six months later I'm in an
Oscars party it's like Madonna [ __ ]
David Blaine but puffy nobody's
everybody nobody and Tom Mr Cruz and I'm
now in a group talking
and I look at him and I go I don't know
if you remember me I did that reading
for the men that uh uh what the fox he
goes like this he goes he goes he goes
it looks at me he just goes yeah how you
doing he doesn't remember and then as
we're talking he's got something he
remembers yeah and he I swear to God I
have a witness to this he goes
you were great in that reading
I remember that was the one you were
great in that reading and I said Thank
you and he goes you are great Katie
Holmes is right here she looks like
she's so over the whole situation and
I'm all due respect but she's used to
this this is what he does he does say
everything he makes everybody in your
parade and I agree and he goes you were
and he kept doing this this is my
impression he goes you were great in
that reading and he goes his timing his
timing I said Thank You 13 times my
friend said he goes how many times I
said how many times I say thank you 13
times I said 13 times because he kept
saying and then we spoke he and I just
he and I for an hour and a half about
our kids and about oh wow life wait a
second so we're both rare rare we're
both high school wrestlers okay I went
to Dan Gable's Camp he couldn't afford
it he went to The Outsiders that's right
so we spoke about that we spoke about
wrestling everything wow Jesus Christ
this is a long time I remember going I
know but I remember
this all started with him gun you ever
met Tom Cruise
that was my top cruise that was my Tom
Cruise experience he's like Brian was
like did you say Tom Cruise Chan get
ready for a 45 minute monologue on top
it's on Tom Cruise but I thought I was
like maybe we'll be friends after this
you never heard from him because he's
heard from him you didn't convert them
he got into an SUV I was gonna tell my
Tom Cruise story but there's so much Tom
Cruise
I'll be back you know I feel like we're
gonna do very well with this one because
you worked no no there's no I sell it
like it's better but the reality is
that's probably the better an hour and a
half
Segway dang what was your Tom Cruise did
he want to know about that he was in
front of me a Jack In The Box and I
beeped I said I don't [ __ ] care if
you're Tom Cruise or not get the [ __ ]
going he paid for your order and then he
paid he goes down the guy he goes you
are great you were great did he talk to
you about stand-up though
he didn't no no he didn't talk to me but
but it was just that moment of like you
felt like you were in his world I'll
show you what my story is very quick
ready somebody said you want very quick
ready you can time this like 20 seconds
tops and what I like he reiterates and
what I like is you got that part of him
he reiterated and this was it he was
talking to somebody else and this person
mutual friend said Tom have you ever uh
met Dane Cook this is Dane Cook and I'm
gonna I'm gonna come to you ready you
can stay seated yeah he goes like this
ready put your hand out he goes he goes
very pleased
very pleased to meet you very very
pleased
and then he went excuse me and what that
meant was you go because he stayed there
so he's excuse me amazing some kind of
now you get out of my grade dude I
backed away I've never backed out of a
I've never disappeared
he's waving like this he's the king all
right have a good day well you part of
your Fame was having a management I can
still feel his hand yes well yes he has
to manage his energy his Essence my
hand's A Lot Like Us admit that by the
way say it that's good I don't even have
you didn't have to push me on it yeah
well do I I played Dane Cook not in that
in that role yeah you were Tom Cruise
remember
so I was a little bit like I was like
I'm confident but I get something but
you grabbed me like you were a person
who just got their hands back endless
experience
full circle flip it clip it Brian Morgan
Freeman
wow now do you say that you say Morgan
Freeman oh my God I was there was this
bus dude tour at Marie callenders Tom
drives really a really interesting Side
Story
we're both hanging
Morgan Freeman played paddle ball when I
played paddle ball right are you okay
you're having an allergic reaction I did
touch nine cats before I shook your hand
gotcha
balloons balloons and Comfortably Numb
place
two balloons to wrap it up on time
because he's like the last Superstar
there's not really no 100 DiCaprio are
kind of like I feel like they're both a
superstar Hollywood thespian like both
top there if they did a movie together
just be like are you kidding me yeah
yeah the thing about Tom Cruise career
no movies bigger than the last Top Gun
yeah and it was [ __ ] awesome dude it
was amazing awesome yeah American Eagle
on my back tattoo after that but I stood
up and [ __ ] clapped at that yeah and
my buddy goes like this because they
lost me I go when oh [ __ ] up he goes in
the beginning he's doing mach 10 when
you eject you you would disappear
but I mean who cares but I was I was
doing that uh I was doing that man cry
during the scene with Kilmer where I was
just like trying to pretend I'm still
watching the movie and wiping like this
yep yeah right I'm still I'm not [ __ ]
it's not a river coming out of my
redness no what makes you cry
um I'm pretty sensitive man a lot of
things I feel like you'd have pretty
thick skin no man let me ask oh no no
yes you get older do you cry more
because as I get older I'm more of a
[ __ ] dude
I wepted the other day listening to uh I
brought up it's funny the way our brains
work I pulled a Foo Fighters reference
for our last little uh improv which was
probably Emmy award-winning if you guys
are up for consideration acoustic
version I think I pulled it yeah that
made me cry walk the walk can we I'm
gonna say that again because there was
kind of some sneezing or some kind of
hay fever happening let me say it again
just oh one second
I was listening to Foo Fighters and and
that brought me to an emotional place so
I'm like I just I I just because of the
memory or what it's just the words
something in the lyrics of that song was
just like uh it it hit me in the right
place
oh yeah what are we looking at oh there
we go yeah if we play it we'll just have
to edit it out if we play no we played
I'm gonna probably it's I'm gonna well
the this version rocks but like whatever
they did for the for the uh unplugged
version was really really emotional yeah
it's good man yeah I just I just I mean
imagine like imagine this is the song
that you listen to there's already keep
going there's a line in it I'll tell you
why it [ __ ] speaks to me you
[ __ ] keep going keep going it's
a long song scroll God damn it that's it
again yeah ready ready it's it's the
ready um oh no go back up if you want to
die no keep going ready ready look at
this line ready he goes um uh see to
keep alive a moment at a time that's
still inside a whisper to a riot the
sacrifice The Knowing to survive the
first decline another state of mind
that's like that that Goosebumps right
here man because like that's that's all
gonna hit that moment where you think
you're [ __ ] Cruising but you might
plummet 100 and for him to put that in a
song no knowing like man no career
nobody is gonna get out unscathed no one
and grow knows it no one that first
decline
my mind
though
wow no they've had moments though I feel
like you're stronger literally when I
met you you were one I feel like you
you're literally like
stronger than you've ever been
physically you're just a big you went
from being built like me and now you're
just a big strong guy with a loud voice
you know what it is your Barrel check
you know what I was missing what I was
missing that [ __ ] the the real
innocence inside of me that I'd buried
for so long that little kid who was so
such a Wallflower and didn't have the
the ability to say hey everybody can can
I be in included can I be invited to the
playground therapist tell you that all
that stuff yeah therapy was the greatest
there was those talk to eight-year-old
Brendan no my therapist what are your
boundaries and that's that that moment I
said what are your boundaries I said I
don't what do you mean like in the
bedroom you're not alone
because it gets pretty loose
hold on there's a [ __ ] truth quick
happening
um
boundaries man that was like a big big
that that was a game changer for me like
oh now you know what happened I was such
a
um I was such uh
um can I have my own thoughts yes can I
find it myself
because we're gonna have to edit his
time crew story out because there's
seven hours so I'm just trying to break
his arm Jesus you're [ __ ] way
stronger than I thought you said no it's
just like I I comedy you know changed my
life and suddenly turned me into the I
had a spectacle moment but I still was
kind of running away from the idea of
like I was this introvert kid with a lot
of social anxiety and I was not the
class client I was not cool and then I
was suddenly cool in the center of
everything which was fine when I was on
stage but I still didn't know how to
really
manage all that in real life and nobody
could help me because I was the first to
even make it to be successful so I
wasn't even like Burr was ahead of me to
go dude I I'm gonna walk you in I got it
so there was a lot of time where I was
like I let everybody in because I
thought like that's love now everybody
likes me because they know me and so
everybody got access and then after
several years I realized Man I'm The
Loneliest and saddest I've been because
I didn't know the boundaries to like
keep certain people at distance and
really mindfulness and I didn't have any
of that [ __ ] so the last 10 years of my
life I've been the happiest and the
healthiest because I finally have all my
you know priorities in order and that's
how you that's why you bully people like
me where you just pick me up and turn me
upside down so I wish somebody had that
on film did you guys forget that you're
doing your job
I felt like I had bird bones look at the
[ __ ] look at the split that's
happening right here in real time
how were those genes even staying
tethered in the middle
just [ __ ] rips apart with that
[ __ ] Mane you know he's got he's got
just like uh one of those green screen
outfits only on his [ __ ] and balls in
case it gets revealed and you have to
quickly hide it as a cucumber emoji
all right Jen hit it all right what are
you doing
what do we got current events so this is
a uh a quick thing I guess there's an
app called podcast I'm gonna actually
let you guys do this I'm gonna bolts
damn it James
All This Is Where I Leave it would have
been better if just you just disappeared
through the stealing you had that kind
of money just say how the [ __ ] did you
wake himself up no what if he's all is
it Brian you say that and what do I do
what's my instinct can I and let me keep
that in one lay away because I was like
all right if I jumped in here and
grabbed onto it maybe I could you looked
up you were like oh wait I always have
to fight you know it's it's we use
everything that's what I love about
Hollywood if it was a crew member on a
film set they'd go give me about 15
minutes
and pull it all up yeah all right you
got those and action action read all
right action uh so you're not on action
first action is background you're on the
second action action background action
so this is a podcast app I get I don't
know it says podcast.ai it's an it's an
AI app and apparently they took Joe
Rogan's voice and Steve Jobs voice and
made them do an interview and it's all
like created by AI so here's a short
sample of it I feel like we're going
down a dangerous road oh freak [ __ ]
welcome to another episode of the Bro
joking experience the Bro joking and on
this episode I welcome my friend who's
difficult to describe this is not Joe no
nope not at all neither one of them it's
great to be on the show your audience is
just so different from your normal Apple
users and that's a good thing they're
both talking like they just uh
recuperated from a stroke rather
recently since the 1980s yeah it's not
polished but it's kind of crazy you can
imagine what if you did a phony phone
call as either of those then you're
gonna have somebody on the line going uh
Joe and love you an hour of that would
be a little much so there is a longer
version but uh you don't want it no no
it's super long so well that's actually
that's are they what are they talking
about are they actually talking about
things of substance no no because in
order to do it there has to be stuff
they've used in the past yeah it comes
in the vernacular so they put it all
together they put it all together oh
that's whoever's doing it's [ __ ] are
they even like mirror [ __ ] they
manipulated you like bro joke he never
said bro joke and ever they put those in
together so it's just you can tell
what's gonna happen in the future it can
be like polished and incredible yeah a
lot of people get canceled and with the
what do you call it the face record yeah
yeah no the face swap
that including yeah this that could be
crazy well didn't Bruce Willis just like
sell his likeness and voice so that they
can continue yeah yeah celebrities are
selling their likeness because that Tom
Cruise one's huge oh yeah it's nice
that guy's amazing yeah
that whole that whole thing that Cruz
does and the reiterating on America Got
Talent they did that but they did for
Elvis so there's a guy who kind it looks
like Elvis not really and he's playing
he can sing and dance but then you look
at the screen and it's Elvis like a like
in real time it's nuts nuts that's
pretty cool though and scary yes I mean
yeah the dark side that's terrifying no
what else you got you uh that's a quick
video I don't know how old this is but
this is uh some kids rollerblading under
a 18-wheeler
this house kids are so nice this has to
be like
but look at this look okay no this guy
goes here no yummy yeah yeah please
don't do that yeah don't show me
something I'm not ready for please don't
do that wait
yeah are you setting this up for
something that's really why not
everyone's good you know it's good I
mean just doing that my resting heart
rate just jumped up
to seven
I hate God these kids are nothing that
just made my crazy my dominant test boys
real tight young boys yeah my right
Wine's bigger I had an undescended until
I was four so the left one's like kind
of like really adorable but my right
ball just got really tight you can't see
me for the ground you hit me you hit a
[ __ ] tire oh who knows oh that's a
terrible yeah those are that's where you
go you'll find those videos on LiveLeak
yeah but then that's like the when
things when bad things happen right yeah
live leak is like somebody in a country
you've never heard of and they're like
uh they're just doing like uh headstands
on like abandoned buildings and then the
concrete just breaks and I watch your
friend yells in that language about it
God damn it there was a guy who's
shooting didn't open and he did he was
they were base jumping and it's in
Russia and he landed in snow this snow
was so deep he was fine you ever seen
that no and his his brothers the base
Germany in Russia his brother his
brother is saying a prayer over his
brothers what he thinks a dead body
crawls out of snow yeah he [ __ ] fell
through the snow the snow is 18 feet
deep they come out adorable like a Saint
Bernard in one of those movies
yeah oh it's in Russia oh yeah it's in
Russia and he's like you're my brother
this is the nuttiest [ __ ] in the world
is the one oh this is yeah there you go
oh
he survived though
he might have died yeah that's the girl
talking alive this happened one word
no this did not like miraculously
however that's my favorite part
yeah unless it's happened multiple times
it has wow anyway well let's not yeah
yeah
I know dude yeah I'm not even gonna say
that I saw something once and I'm like I
won't say it oh please do it no come on
dark dude
yeah but like the real hardcore like
where you're like how did this even get
on the internet man this is it was just
crazy it was huh it wasn't it was a
beheading oh I don't know oh I I watched
Daniel and not an instant one oh my God
I think I've seen they have the Dual
knives
because you hear the guy going yeah
it's like a butter knife can we play any
game like can we just play a game right
now
I'm laughing at Joe listen yeah
get us out of this another Well Tom was
I've had to do this with some cougars
after a show know what I mean guys
what is this one this is Rogan's this is
Rogan's uh yeah there's Joe Rogan's
Instagram and he's just reposting this
video of this guy with a gun and a
cougar basically trying to attack the
guy and the guy just doesn't shoot I
didn't watch the entire video so I'll
just play it for you guys watch I did
what is it like a mountain lion yeah
why is this guy shoot up in the air
that's one bulletin chamber that's a
good point too you see speaking English
to it
I say you run toward it why would you
say get back like he knows what the [ __ ]
you're doing why not I'd be shooting at
the ground right here for him to pounce
oh
and he's still staying there oh this is
a whole different thing happening now
did he hit it no
put the phone down to Rogan's pole I
wish Foo Fighters walk started playing
right now no he knew it would go viral
this is awesome wow that's that cat's
not afraid he's not afraid at all wow he
or she
got it backing up the cat's like oh
right it's kind of crazy that that cat
is barely Fearless sitting that gun that
loudness and everything doesn't matter
I've never seen it yeah
guy's got some good lungs though
all right
real strong breaths right there a lot of
dogs
your doctor is like a few more and
you're like I don't know if I have one
more stethoscope around to go with you
here I'm getting a little light-headed
there but all right Governor I got one
more that's a that's it I kind of want
you to hear something so we can just
move away from the breathing and into
the how do I fix myself I'll [ __ ] uh
deal with a cougar or a grizzly bear any
day so all right you got some more here
oh fun so oh well that's all yeah would
you do this it's a hammerhead he's
putting him in tonic
and all I have is those cartons the
people did the the carton Challenge on
dude
shark challenge it's how you lose your
arm how you use your arm uh hell no I
wouldn't do this like do you guys like
do you ever watch this and just go like
this looks like a shark having fun like
I see that the fun in that like I don't
see a vicious moment there is like a big
dog it's like a big dog yeah it's like a
big water dog yeah the dog with fins
right it's 100 teeth yeah with a with a
mouth big enough too I told you this I
go how bored are these [ __ ] guys well
it's pretty like there's some Gardens
down there just [ __ ] with the sharks
[Music]
those are tiger sharks by the way that's
a tiger shark no I'm not doing any of
that yeah that's insane you need to put
that uh that's uh that dude
and it just makes it more Whimsical I
bet those sharks when they swam away and
whatever the way sharks think it was
like that was a fun time with those
people he's trying to put them in tonic
about the milk Gardens down they brought
toys yeah
the milk cartons just for protection
stupid [ __ ] a border those people I
don't know what that is
and what is this this is cool this
dolphin is doing this deliberately okay
Dan dolphins are drawn to you
so pretty interesting dolphin story
actually oh it's making little bubbles
oh neat that he's amused by this right
oh this is so magical and at first I
thought it was CGI
but it's not that is for sure it's not
fake because they sure do look fake and
they're practicing all day yeah they
look pretty fake hey you guys don't know
[ __ ] about dolphins oh he blew it out of
his little blowhole up on the top bet
you Tom Cruise can do that underwater he
looks up and he's like yeah it did it
how bored how bored is this dolphin this
has to be like Sea World some [ __ ] yeah
this Dolphins hating his life that's a
pool he's like you know I'm just gonna
blow some [ __ ] things yeah
you have a cool dolphin story it's at St
Petersburg Florida 2004 me and my buddy
Al we go out jet skiing we see a pod of
dolphins because it's a pod it's uh not
a herd or a gag Tom Cruise comes in and
he actually said I just came from
Collins let me tell you an hour and 45
minute story that took place it's The
Abridged no
um we jumped off the jet skis to swim
with the dolphins in real time the
[ __ ] guy who rented he comes
barreling out and he's screaming get the
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of the one and he
explains to us there's there's calves
there's baby dolphins and then they'll
kill you yes they will these Mo these
moms because they're they don't they're
not fun it's not Sea World we were
trying to Pat we're swimming we're like
dude this is surreal we're doing this on
Earth in the ocean and this guy [ __ ]
screamed obscenities and pulled us out
Dolphins
their babies yeah and you're just we're
trying to swim
you know when somebody yells at you so
much too that like you know you deserved
it but you're still like I mean like the
amount of yelling you know it sounds
like I understood that we had to get out
of the water but like I felt really
chastised by that was it a lot it felt
like a lot
pretty aggressive yeah that's there's a
limit oh I love football what do we got
it yeah you're a huge Sports who's your
team Patriots love Yeah Patriots
Patriots
that's a flag on the play right there
that's a flag that's unsportsman like
this is so that's on Sportsman like and
it's mockery let me see this again what
is happening two things that I don't
value
oh wow
I like how they think the ref is
listening to them yeah his argument yeah
yeah meanwhile he's a panther yeah
there you go well
what about Colby coming down
you mainly watch football thing uh yeah
which one yeah yeah I watch everything
but I like football the most
let's see this what's this now Marcus so
Jason yeah how do you say it sudakis
what is that what is sudakis that's a
good question uh that is Greek I think
sudakis I'm gonna say it's either Greek
or it's like check do you think do you
think his nickname was Lithuanian
sedakis to his buds
Lithuanian is that what I saw up there
it says Georgia Lithuania ah
I've heard from people that know yeah
yeah people in the notes say that she's
she's just a [ __ ] narcissist she's
really pretty she's stupid pretty she
could [ __ ] in my bed Johnny Depp style
I'd be fine with it yeah but I guess she
left the Apple watch behind and he
catches her texting with Harry Styles
during the filming of that movie yeah
yep call that a meant to be moment yeah
that's gotta suck man yeah that hurts
especially since trying to read all of
that on an Apple Watch
Once they have the ultra which I'm
rocking far more screen space higher
resolution deeper richer colors the
blacks are like black yeah you don't
need your phone
I can't throw himself under her car what
then Eddie says when I came back from
weekend off Jason was crying a lot
crying crying I didn't know what
happened yeah yeah that's crying crying
a lot
yeah and she should have said and I was
proud of him because it's amazing when
you could see a man of his stature let
it all go not for that long but yeah I
hear you yeah
crying and crying things
which one the Rex Ryan one okay
so I guess this guy right after this guy
Duane's Haskins died he felt the need to
comment like you know I knew he wasn't
going to do well in the NFL let's see
many times it's like oh hey buddy like
boy just
foot and mouth disease huh yeah
if you know anything about Rex's foot
fetishes that joke actually lands
Baker Mayfield is overrated as hell do
you guys want to remember I said that
and I also said Daniel Jones
when he came out ahead of this guy this
Haskins that everybody
would struggle in the National Football
League
hold on pause that pause that he's
talking about a football skills black
and white he's not talking about his
personal life so yeah Dwayne Hastings
passed away and had some issues he was
saying Dwayne Haskins was picked ahead
of these other football players and
Dwayne Haskins coming into the league
had a lot of baggage he's like
everyone's high and mighty on Dwayne uh
uh Haskins he's talking about just
football he shouldn't have to apologize
for that Duane Haskins really struggled
in the NFL he was explaining why he's
the guy got hit by the truck yes playing
wise he's not talking about Dwayne
Haskins abilities to you know I think
was the issue that the timing of it
though was he talking about this right
around the same time that he was or is
this like it's not a too soon thing
right it's like October 17th so just
today
I'm just breaking up okay if it happened
like the day or the day after like uh
even then if you're talking about just
straight football ability a quarterback
that's all he was talking about okay
he's like look I call this this no the
statue of limitations was fine on this
at that point yeah I'm good with that as
well not too soon
there's no two suit name where you ever
get on Twitter and just see like an hour
after something happens and you're like
who's coming down to comedians when the
whole [ __ ] Squad is in here
unbelievable like yeah
uh so I guess Phil Knight's putting a
lot of money into this uh Oregon
governor race to keep the Republican
we've talked about this a little bit how
um you know people aren't super happy
with the way Oregon is shaping up with
yeah and Phil nice donating to the
Republican party because he wants Oregon
to turn red right well you just don't
want this insane like far left Insanity
it's destroying cities like San
Francisco Seattle and Portland give me a
break if we could just scroll to the
right because we donated to the Democrat
Oregon yeah
those casual boots Phil Knight donated
one million oh no Phil Knight donated
one million to Republicans
he's also giving 3.7 million to
Independent candidates he's saying I'll
take anything but the Democrat what the
Blue's done to poor organ is horrible
yeah
exactly I'm still stuck on the Spanish
boot there I was actually looking at
those and they're popping up that's
right
definitely looking for Spanish dance
boots yeah is that it uh let me see
what's going on here okay go for it
dishes on dear friend prince Andrew
especially I have a question about just
land Maxwell for all you
conspiracy-minded people
um she was she was convicted for drug
for for sex trafficking but to who was
it just Jeff rubstein like where are the
people she was yeah that's what they're
saying just Jeffrey Epstein he was the
master man behind it but but did any
other names come up who happen to have
been in that oh yeah house that were
having sex with these girls so how come
I haven't heard about them prince Andrew
yeah but what about the other people do
you think it just gets buried because
there's way too many uh they said in the
black books and politicians yeah so so I
don't know yeah that's what's
interesting yeah she said it was a
special friendship which continued over
the years Maxwell said of her close ties
with Clinton we had lots in common I
feel bad we have lots in common Bill
Clinton's like not helping my car and
she said I feel bad that he's another
victim only because of his association
with Jeffrey well yeah because he flew
to the island something like 40 times he
had some questions Bill Clinton
consummate that's her yeah that's her
that's her now yeah man I I it'll still
remain a mystery why she didn't go to a
country that couldn't extradite her but
she was just sitting in that place that
in New Hampshire I don't know especially
when they came down on them they're
gonna wrap you pretty tight
all right I think that's pretty much it
yeah there's a you're not on Twitter
right Dean on your am I what on tour no
okay
right now danecook.com above it all yeah
wait when does this go live today oh
okay so it's on moment until uh
Wednesday Thursday and then it'll switch
over to danecook.com I love it so you
can get it on moment all the merch all
the cool stuff to go along with it and
then I'm gonna pull all that stuff up
off there and it'll just be the special
online if you want to watch it right now
go to a moment that's CEO ding right now
right now yeah go watch it above it all
Man filmed on the porch I know I know
great to see you we love you man thanks
for having me you always you always have
a standing invite we've been trying to
get you on I appreciate it I watch it so
now I'm like oh I'm in the thing where
I've finally seen everybody else sitting
having some fun dude it's smaller than
you thought huh
and
you're filling out Salt Lake City come
on out this Thursday Friday Saturday
we'll have a fight campaign as well live
in Salt Lake City that's at noon uh
Mountain Time live on thick boy YouTube
uh fight campaign with Frank Mir and
myself some other guests but Salt Lake
City Wise Guys this Thursday through
Saturday the next week Thursday show at
the Rooftop in Calgary is damn near sold
out so we had a show on Friday there
will be a fight coming on Saturday for
Jake Paul Anderson Silva uh San Antonio
is November 3rd through the 5th Houston
November 10th and 12th get your tickets
at thickboy.com come see me at the uh
Schaumburg improv Charlotte Chicago
Improv Schaumburg Illinois Dane Cook is
opening for me October 27 28 29. then I
got Charlotte North Carolina Comedy Zone
November 10 11 12. Addison Texas Addison
Improv November 17 19. finally in Naples
off the hook December one through four
that it doesn't stop won't stop cancer
can't stop Boston uh your hometown I
love it man I said my dad up there and
I'm like 31st baby yeah damn we love you
go watch this special all right thanks
that was a great pot yeah